definitivamente es un momento tenso los
principales medios de comunicación de
todo el mundo que se congregan acá en la
casa blanca y a las afueras de la casa
blanca están todos pues muy activo
reportando precisamente esta noticia
esta intervención de el candidato
demócrata yo bailé pero hay que resaltar
también que en filadelfia hace unos
minutos también hablo ericsson hijo de
donald trump dice eric trump que lo que
está pasando es que pues le están
quitando le están robando arrebatando la
elección presidencial a su padre sobre
todo en pensilvania y este una de las
cosas que resaltó el candidato demócrata
joe biden es en su alocución en su breve
alocución una locución en donde se
mostró tranquilo aunque como nuestro nos
decía a nuestra corresponsal mamen sala
en nueva york está muy cansado también y
de pronto eso pudo haber influido pero
en todo caso pues lo que decía yo bailé
era que el 78 por ciento de los votos
por correo
se están contabilizando en pensilvania
son votos demócratas y esto podría ser
que pues ese estado y sus bonos y sus 20
otros electorales terminen siendo de los
demócratas entonces es de resaltar eso
ya hablo yo bailé desde delaware pero
también desde pensilvania desde
filadelfia hubo una respuesta por parte
de with front y de la reacción diciendo
que lo que puede haber acá es un fraude
sobre todo lo que tiene que ver con
pensilvania